[Music]  so what are your parents like are they  as square as mine  lorraine lately i've come to conclusion  that i don't know anything about my  parents  why are you so nervous well have you  ever been  like in a situation where well you know  you have to act a certain way but  but when you get there you're not sure  you can really go through with it  like when you're out on a first date  with someone well sort of  [Music]  but you're good marty you're really good  and that audition tape of yours is great  you've got to send it to the record  company i think either  what if they say get out of here kid you  got no future  why should i put myself through all that  anxiety oh  jesus  well you know they say that all of our  emotional anxiety comes from our parents  in that case you can kiss me  right now